merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur julien dive
merci monsieur président sur le premier
ministre nous vous prions d'accepter nos
excuses pour la gêne occasionnée
cette phrase résonne tous les jours dans
au moins une garde notre pays
annonciatrice d'une journée qui commence
mal
elle fait partie du quotidien du
majorité de français nous vous prions
d'accepter nos excuses pour la gêne
occasionnée
c'est aussi ce que devrait dire le
gouvernement pour sa politique de
transport parce que la matière vous
n'êtes vraiment pas à l'heure des
installations vétustes un mois de
novembre 2016 record avec des retards
une accessibilité paix mer avec des gars
insuffisante et qui ne sera effective
partout en france qu en 2024 pour les
usagers prendre les transports est une
question d'accès à l'emploi à la
formation à la culture
c'est pourtant un sujet vous prenez bien
à la légère ne vous étonnez plus du
sentiment d'abandon de cette france qui
prend le train tous les jours
heureusement si on peut le dire les
usagers peuvent compter sur leur
imagination avec les applications
collaboratives ou le covoiturage est
plutôt que de prendre ses
responsabilités le gouvernement se
débarrasse des problèmes qui ne veut
plus gérer vous avez mis le couteau sous
la gorge aux régions pour qu'elles
reprennent la gestion des intercités et
trains vieillissants de moins en moins
fréquentées et dont il est urgent
d'améliorer le service en matière
d'accessibilité pmr la situation devient
rocambolesque nous avons inauguré il ya
un mois un nouveau parvis de la gare à
saint quentin
accessible à tous les publics formidable
me direz vous oui mais nous devrons
attendre 2022 pour que la gare et les
trains soit aux normes
pourquoi l'état métier la pression sur
les communes et n'a pas les mêmes
exigences vis-à-vis de la sncf
vous le voyez les communes les régions
doivent pallier aux défaillances
alors que les transports restent de la
compétence de l'état encore une fois les
élus locaux doivent payer le prix de
votre renoncement
ces symptômes de votre désertion me font
poser une question simple monsieur le
premier ministre votre gouvernement est
une vision et des solutions pour les
transports de notre pays ou décide-t-il
d'abdiquer
la parole et comme monsieur alain
vidalies secrétaire d'état chargé des
transports de la mer et de la pêche
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député je trouve votre question bien
imprudente
parce que si vous voulez d'abord
l'héritage mais ça fait partie si vous
voulez en parler d'abord comment un
député peut ici dire les transports
c'est de la compétence de l'état me
semble que la moindre des choses c'est
au moins de respecter de respecter
l'état des compétences et chacun ici à
part vous c'est parfaitement que pour
les ter c'est à dire les transports du
quotidien c'est de la compétence des
régions et depuis bien longtemps je
pense que vous devriez vous imposer le
respect de la loi ensuite il faut savoir
moi j'ai des gauchers avec des élus de
votre majorité est certaine que vous
connaissez bien ailleurs et qui ont été
beaucoup plus constructif et qui sont
très heureux de signer avec le
gouvernement
les accords qui font que les 3 milliards
5 dont j'ai parlé seront au rendez-vous
justement pour apporter cette réponse et
je préfère cette démarche avec
l'association des régions de france avec
le président richert avec tous les
présidents qu'ils soient de droite ou de
gauche constructive que le caractère
polémique de votre rêve de votre
question de car en fait si vous voulez
le débat quand nous sommes arrivés il y
avait sur l'ensemble sur l'ensemble des
crédits d'entretien un milliard cinq est
aujourd'hui ces trois milliards c'est à
dire que ce gouvernement non seulement a
fait l'effort mais il a d'abord dû
consacrer l'argent des concitoyens à
réparer vos oublie à réparer vos erreurs
et je pense que votre question de ce
point de vue là était particulièrement
imprudente
merci la séance des questions au
gouvernement est terminée